hello everyone and welcome back to kappa
blanka saga we are returning to the 1911
tournament of san sebastian we have a
game between josé raúl capablanca with
the white pieces and english grandmaster
well not really grandmaster english
chess master almost burned who is the
oldest participant of this tournament
this is a game from round 3 we skip the
game from round two work up a Blanca
faced his old nemesis Frank Marshall not
because we've already seen too much
games between capablanca and Frank
Marshall but rather as it was a really
quick draw so I decided to skip that one
so first we had that game against Aussie
Bernstein where Bernstein really wanted
to beat kappa blanka then in the end he
ended up losing and well as he was the
one who protested to the chief arbiter
about capablanca even participating in
this tournament couple mark I was very
glad that he was able to beat him but he
was not the only player that protested
aron nimzowitsch was amongst other
players who protested and you know in
between games Capablanca challenge names
of each to a series of speed games for
money as in those game is in those days
if you challenge someone you did it for
money and s-capepod Monica mentions
there are different sources saying you
know in what fashion couple monk was
able to beat him Civic but it does say
that he did beat him with quite a result
something like if they played let's say
six games that it was five to one and
which is not the only player that kappa
blanka beat in speed games during the
official games but it doesn't state who
else did he beat
so everyone was silenced and Capablanca
was allowed to continue playing his
tournament normally so like I said in
wish Chessmaster almost burned who did
not consider himself as just
professional even though he's been
playing chess his entire life he's a
really strong tournament player he
defeated the players like Alexander Ali
and he finished in tournaments where
Emanuel Lasker played ahead of Emanuel
Lasker and I believe in one tournament
he even shared first with William
Steinitz he was born in 1848 so that's
not even ten years
that's eight years after Paul Morphy and
he's still an active chess player here
playing in the sand Sabathia 1911
tournament with josé raúl capablanca so
without further ado let's check out this
game Capablanca has the white pieces
let's see how he faces against one of
the strongest players of that era again
come on monk opens with E 4 we have E 5
and 9 f3 Knight to c6 and now Bishop to
b5 the rule opus is on the board we have
a 6 more fees defense brush up to a 4 we
have Knight to f6 and now comes d3 again
capablanca mentions that in his older
days when he was you know well versed in
the art of the opening theory he would
have perhaps the gone c3 or d4 but here
he still played this Timothy d3 move we
have d6 c3 Bishop to e7 Knight B to d2
going for the standard maneuver were
white castles rook e1 the night goes to
f1 and then either
III or g3 black castles and here kappa
blanka doesn't castle instead he first
goes Knight to f1 he decides to keep his
King in the center a little bit longer
and a burn goes for a very principled
decision first b5 we have disrupted not
b3 sorry about that
Bishop the c2 rather Bishop to c2 and
now d5 a very principled decision as
capablanca asking he's still stuck in
the center so we do want to break open
the position we have Queen to e2 and now
D captures on e4 d captures on e4 and
now Bishop to c5 Capablanca mentions in
his book that he didn't like this Bishop
to c5 move you're using the piece you
already developed twice in the opening
there are other pieces to develop her
like Bishop d6 was definitely an idea
and there's no real reason of moving
this piece twice yes this is a much
better diagonal for this Bishop that's
true but you know it's also wasting a
move as couple more conventions but okay
Bishop to g5 and there isn't a slow move
white can actually play that where you
can actually use this for example if you
could get Knight g4 in and
Tech f2 even if white played the the
slowest of moves like better to d2
there's still no point in doing it
but okay Bishop to g5 by kappa blanka
now pinning this night we have Bishop to
e6 and now Knights the e3 rook to e8
capablanca castles and now Knight to d5
is definitely a threat you want to pile
up on the pinned piece and you will
force black either to lose the bishop
pair by playing Bishop captures on e3 or
after a knife comes to d5 we will have
to capture with your LightSquared Bishop
here Queen to e7 was played and now
capablanca centralizes his knight a very
natural move Knight to d5 and now you
have to capture it if you go something
like Queen b8 then you get a bunch of
characters G captures and then your pawn
structure is all messed up the night is
still very strong here you can go rook
81 simply protect the night and put put
a rock on a very nice open D file and
the white will be much better here
so after Knight d5 we have bushel
captures he captures you have to go back
with the night if you go to a five you
get before and you lose the piece
Knights the b8 and now comes a for the
rooks are no longer connected and
Capablanca does again a very principled
decision by attacking the flank here so
what can black do here you don't want to
capture on e4 that will leave the king a
queen side pawns very vulnerable another
thing you could do is let's say Knight
bd7 connect rooks but then again simply
captures captures captures captures and
you lose the b5 pawn and the black could
actually use this for some sort of
initiative or activity in the center
will be ie4 but still there's no real
compensation to it and he decides not to
go for it against Capablanca as
Capablanca is still a new player so so
far the only thing people know is that
he beat Marshall in a match he be
awesome Bernstein in round one he didn't
drew a game against Marshall in round
two and he beat a lot of strong players
in speed chess in between classical
games so okay after a four we have b4
and it's very interesting how kappa
blanka makes use of this he plays
seek after Sun before Bishop captures
now capablanca decides to willingly
relinquish the bishop repair Bishop
captures on f6 and it comes with a very
strong idea if for example G captures on
f6 seems like okay you're maybe messing
up your pawn structure a bit but you're
strengthening in the center this would
lose instantly but I feel free to pause
the video here it's it's a very nice
idea how does how does white win here
I'll give you a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent tactician and for those of you
who are you know just interested in
enjoying the show the idea is d6 simply
making room for your Queen to come to e4
and attack the rook that is undefended
since the knight was forced to go on b8
where the rooks are not connected after
you do something about it as the Queen
is also under attack see characters you
get Queenie for attacking the h7 point
attack in the bishop on before and also
attacking the rook on a8 this is just
wonderful and I might also use this as a
thumbnail since it's so wonderful and
you have you have to lose the rook if
you protect the rook then it's checkmate
Queen h7 king of a - the Queen - a trade
will be checkmate
so after this Bishop f6 Queen captures
on f6 was played but now again a very
strong Queen to e4 attacking the bishop
undefended still threatening h7 and well
you cannot give up your bishop you have
to allow Queen captures on h7 so at
least you go here and okay Queen
captures on h7 grabbing a pawn King to
f8 and mountain Knights to h4 a couple
Blanc is basically forcing almost to
force kappa blanka into a queen trade if
you just continue our game let's say 97
you continue developing you get Queen h8
check King here and now Knight a5 check
after the King moves you will grab the
pawn on g7 and now black will be down
two points and you don't want to be down
two points against kappa blanka and on
the other hand after this Knight a5
check you don't have the option of the
in-between Queen captures with the idea
that personal captures you will only
then recapture because here Y could
first grab the rook and only after real
capture special captures and you would
be up opponent of the exchange so after
this night
h4
Queen to h6 was played in here kappa
blanka happily trades into and into an
end game Maya Queen captures we have
pawn captures and now Knight to f5 going
after the pawn h5 but you will not be
able to protect this pawn bishop the big
one attacks the pawn and now you will
lose the H bone as well Knight d7 Bishop
capture some h5 and now Knight to f6
forcing the bishop back you can't really
protect the pond with the bishop to f3
as efore is coming so kappa blanka
immediately goes to e2 and now comes the
Knight captures on d5 Capablanca is now
up only 1 point but it's a test H pawn
and if we all know that past bones are
the fastest of bones
so rook F to D 1 attacking the knight
Knight f4 attacking the bishop and now
butter up the c4
we have rook e to D 8 now comes h4 it's
a passed pawn so kappa blanka decides to
push it
a5 not making the Epona targets on a
da-a-ate rook can move g3 forcing the
knight back 96 and now Bishop captures
pawn captures and now couple monk I
still up only 1 point but he managed the
double black sea pawns and now he has to
connected passed pawns and that's even
better and now it's only a matter of
technique and if Capablanca has
something that's definitely ending
technique Knights the e3 we have rook
rook d2 b 8 and now comes Knights the C
for protecting the pawn also pressuring
the bishop here King to e7 now comes
rook a to C 1 and now rook to a7 now we
have rook to e1 by kappa blanka and now
King to have 6 giving further protection
to the e5 pawn but now rook to e4
increasing the activity and preparing to
pull the pawns on the Kings side we have
looked up before they're pinning tonight
as the rock on e4 is unguarded but now
g4 no dangers here we have rock 36 and
now comes Luke the c3 preparing rope to
f3 check the shove the c5 and now rook
to f3 check King the g7 and now comes
the b3 and if you look at this position
you see what beautiful masterpiece cover
monk has created this rook can go
anywhere this rook has to stay
a file protecting the a 5-pound this
rock is very nicely protecting the base
of the pawn chain
there's no way to further increase the
attack on this pawn as it's on a light
square as well as the a4 point is on a
like square where burn has the dark
square bishop so there really isn't
anything burn can do but wait you know
for the inevitable but should be for in
deciding to defend d5 pawn but not
really as if capablanca wanted he he
could win it but this wall basically
works in Kappa Blancas favor he was king
g2 brings the King into the game as it
is the endgame we look Tony 8 and now g5
burns simply repeats moves you can't
leave the a file as the a 5 point would
fall so look back to a6 and now comes h5
we have rook captures on c4 here Byrne
decides to give up the exchange as well
he doesn't really have any other moves
to do so he decides to go for rook
captures on c4 we have B captures on c4
and now comes rock to c6 attacking the
c4 pawn but after g6 almost burned
decided to resign the game and after the
first three rounds Capablanca is two
wins and one draw against Frank Marshall
sure that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it around 3 of the 1911 sense of
ASEAN tournament why did he resign after
rook captures or whatever black plays
simply rook to f7 check King has the
Mook in created and h6 is coming again
black can do some threats here but not
really as that's also protected by the
rock kind of 7 h7 check is coming King
h8 or let's say here you have to go to
h8 rocker fate king here now the Queen
comes into the game and after King
captures then comes rook the g4
checkmate one such line that is possible
here sir after g6
almost burned resigned the game and a
beautiful victory for josé raúl
capablanca who is doing excellently in
this tournament especially he since he
really wants to prove himself
it's his first big international
tournament and since everyone doesn't
think that he should even participate he
really wants to do as
you know as as great as possible sir
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you are enjoying the kappa
blanka saga so far I would like to thank
David Sachs Paul staples Adam Scruggs
Anton Scirocco insurgent Georgia which
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos your thing tool for watching and
I will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content and sorry about
if my if my voice is a bit weird I think
I'm coming down with something but you
know it's it's inevitable it's that time
of the year but yeah I have an excellent
rest of the Saturday and I will see you
soon